that warning from a doctor a year to
save the NHS do you recognize that well
do you recognize the financial pressures
across the NHS but what I'd say is it's
not just the NHS as your previous report
showed you need to look at this as the
wider picture of prevention we call
Public Health social care and the NHS
together so the call that I and others
across political parties in Westminster
have made to the government is to say
look at this the whole system look at
what it needs here and now but also look
10 years into the future and do the long
term planning for the sheer scale of the
increase in demand that we have now for
health and social care
indeed I mean social care is that our
topic that we've previously covered in
one of our films on the show we have now
seen the health secretary expand his
brief some what we have this new
Minister for loneliness and do you see
though with these these ministerial
changes the government doing anything
other than being lip service well I mean
they are bringing out a green paper and
social care and as you say that it's
welcome that they've appointed a
minister for notice what we now need is
for all of this to be tied up together
but it is an issue of funding that
clearly that that's important also an
issue of workforce and long term
planning but what I think we do need to
do is actually have those really honest
discussions with people about how we
bring that funding in how we make that
fair across generations and not just
look at that in the context of older
adults social care but the whole system
and I'm afraid in a hung parliament it's
very difficult to get these challenging
decisions across the line because whilst
everybody agrees that the health service
needs more money the challenge comes in
who is actually going to pay for that
and my view is that we need to actually
build a cross-party consensus to go out
and explain these difficult decisions to
people because I'm absolutely convinced
of the case that the Health Service and
Social Care need more money but what I
want to see now is action putting that
in place and explaining to people who
who is going to be making more of a
contribution in order for us to do that
we turn to the winter crisis and it
certainly feels as if we were through
the worst of all of that within the NHS
but I mean what's your assessment of
just
but it got this year well it did get
particularly bad as I say because of the
ongoing financial pressures but also
there's just a loss of that sort of
flexibility to deal with bumps in the
road like for example the flu epidemic
that we had and norovirus coming at the
same time and that can actually lead to
the whole system appearing to grind to a
halt now the NHS did have a plan and
that is put in place to try and relieve
those pressures by by not carrying out
routine surgery but the trouble then is
that those those people who've been
waiting for routine surgery not only is
that a huge inconvenience and a major
problem for those individuals but of
course it then means that the whole
backlog for routine care starts to build
up and that's what we we worrying about
as well as whether the NHS over the
coming year will be able to keep its
commitments to routine surgery so
routine procedures that those will tend
to build up so what we'll see is not as
as the doctors speaking to the March
said that the NHS will collapse and not
be there what we will see is that
waiting times will increase and and the
the lack of the ability to deal with
bumps in the road so effectively because
of the sheer scale of the building
pressure and the fact that we haven't
sufficiently planned for that over
successive governments why has there
been this that this lack of planning for
something which we know is going to
happen if every single year I mean you
wrote this in Express just a little
earlier a little earlier this year there
is nothing new about winter pressures in
the NHS what has changed is that those
pressures are no year-round but in
winter the crisises is far deeper I mean
it's an abrogation of the responsibility
of those in charge isn't it well what we
have called for along with the members
of the House of Lords who looked at this
is to have an office of Health and Care
sustainability a bit like we have the
office of Budget Responsibility an
office that's specifically looking at
the scale of future demand and the
workforce that we need to meet that
demand which states that it's been the
lack of long-term planning that that's
very obvious to those who are looking
closely at the system and
the the the lack of determination to
look at those systems together so it's
very encouraging that that they've now
renamed Jeremy Hunt's role as the the
health and and social care minister but
that can't just be a change of brand
over the door that has to translate into
real action into the way that they
organize and look at funding for the
Health Service so so I think what Teresa
may must do is not just go ahead with a
single green paper looking at older
adult social care but broaden that out
and bring in the funding that's
realistic funding to meet the demand or
at least explain to people if they're
not prepared to put in the extra money
in honest terms what that means for the
level of services and I think that if
the public clearly have that set out for
them what it would mean if we don't
increase the funding then I think they
would be prepared to see some extra
funding coming and that will come have
to be all of us contributing to that in
some way in a fair way but unless you've
set out what those alternatives are it's
very difficult to have those
conversations that say well this is what
it's going to mean in terms of your
national insurance contributions or your
or taxation contributions but we have to
move forward with that
we can't keep ducking it I just want to
change focus slightly for a second dr.
Wallace didn't I don't know whether
you've had that had the chance to get
through the Sunday papers today but once
again there is a huge amount of
speculation about the future the
longevity of Theresa May what do you
make of her leadership yes well I think
it's very unfortunate for people to be
speculating in this way because actually
undermining her leadership at such a
crucial point in our negotiations I
think he's deeply unhelpful so I wish
those cabinet ministers that were out on
maneuvers would just row back because
what we need is to be presenting a
united front of course there are
differences in opinion in the way that
we should be handling brexit if everyone
knows that it's the same in all
political parties that there's a range
of views around things like the single
market and the customs union but have
that translate into people making
threats that that they will be bringing
her
if she doesn't do what they want I think
it's deeply unhelpful what we need to be
doing is for ministers to be having
those conversations in cabinet and not
shouting them all over the Sunday
newspapers I think that's deeply
unhelpful